The French Revolution, explained like you are five.
Step one, in 1789, France is broke.
Decades of wars, a lavish royal court at Versailles,
bad harvests, the country is bankrupt,
and the people are starving.
King Louis XVI calls a meeting of the Estates General
for the first time in 175 years.
The three Estates, the clergy, the nobility,
and everyone else, everyone else is 97% of France,
and they have exactly one vote.
The same as the clergy, the same as the nobility,
so the 97% walk out and form their own assembly.
Step two, Louis panics and locks them out
of their meeting hall,
so they gather at a nearby tennis court
and swear an oath not to leave
until France has a constitution.
Louis backs down.
But in Paris, the rumor spreads
that the king is gathering troops to crush the assembly.
On July 14, 1789, the people of Paris storm the Bastille.
The Bastille is a royal prison, a symbol of royal tyranny.
There are exactly seven prisoners inside when they take it.
The symbol matters more than what's in it.
Step three, the revolution spreads across France like fire.
Nobles flee the country.
The church loses its land.
Feudalism is abolished overnight.
In 1791, France gets its first constitution.
Louis is still king, but his power is now limited.
And here's the thing.
Louis tries to flee France in disguise.
He is recognized at a small town called Varen,
brought back to Paris in humiliation,
and the trust gone forever.
Step four, in 1792, France declares war
on Austria and Prussia.
The foreign powers want to crush the revolution
before it spreads to their own countries.
The war goes badly at first.
Paris panics.
Radical revolutionaries take over.
Louis is arrested, tried for treason,
and executed by guillotine on January 21, 1793.
The crowd cheers the revolution,
no longer interested in a constitutional monarchy.
Now it wants a republic,
and it is willing to kill anyone who disagrees.
Step five, what follows is called the reign of terror.
A revolutionary committee called
the Committee of Public Safety takes control,
led by Maximilien Robespierre.
Anyone suspected of being an enemy of the revolution
is arrested, suspected, not convicted, suspected.
17,000 people are officially executed.
Perhaps 40,000 die in prison or without trial.
Robespierre signs the death warrants.
He calls it necessary.
He calls it virtue.
Step six, in July 1794, Robespierre himself is arrested
by the same men who helped him arrest everyone else.
They are afraid they are next.
He is guillotined the following day.
The instrument of the revolution
used on the revolution's own leader.
Napoleon Bonaparte watches all of this
from a distance, takes careful notes,
and in 1799 walks into the chaos and takes power.
The revolution that promised liberty,
equality, and fraternity ends with a military dictatorship.
The idea survives.
The execution consumed itself,
and that's just one story inside Paladin.
It's like Duolingo, but for history lovers.
Download it now and become the most intelligent person
in the room.